the Supreme Court has ruled the arrest
was unlawful are you still hopeful that
the high court when in fact
the thing is the thing is that um the
one first of all the government has
nothing to do with this arrest and I've
said that
um many a times with facts uh because
this arrest was made under a corruption
case allegation do you have faith in
your Supreme Court
as an institution yes as individuals I
have questions
what are they I mean if the perception
is that a person under trial which has
never happened in the history of the law
the court that a person who's under
investigation in napco under under
physical remand a person is given a
relief in 48 hours has never done that
before in our in our legal history are
you suggesting that the Supreme Court
as I said as I said Supreme Court as an
institution I'm not saying anything
because there are Judges I'm talking
about the individuals and the perception
when such orders are made I can after
the order it is my constitutional right
to analyze the order to discuss the
order to cite the order or to criticize
the order there have been multiple
opportunities to arrest Imran Khan
why do you think now
Pakistani paramilitaries pulling him
from a court
pushing him into a van
was the right way to do it
um what what if I ask you what were the
other opportunities I didn't understand
that there was one opportunity every
time Imran Khan left every time yeah
every he didn't leave he only left his
residence when he was called by the
court every time he was called by the
court as I said before the courts were
attacked so
that justifies sending armed
paramilitaries in to pull him from a
court why something that there's no no I
think the government no the government
has not sent anybody the national
accountability
organization Bureau has a legal right to
ask the forces the way they did it but
the forces to do that if somebody
whoever it is if I defy court if I idify
orders if I am not ready to answer law
of the land I think the same treatment
should be done with me also and you'd be
happy to see him arrested in the same
way if he if he has committed crime
everybody picked up no no everybody
everybody everybody a person who defies
courts as I said before a person who do
does not abide by the law a person who
uh avoids uh Court answer answerable and
who thinks that he's Untouchable who
thinks he cannot be questioned he has to
be treated the way every person in
Pakistan every certain citizen is
treated Mr Khan according to the polls
is Pakistan's current most popular
politician was this simply an attempt to
silence him and given we're in the
situation we not now are has this not
just played into his hands politically I
humbly disagree one because the polls
are different and they are different
poles from different organizations some
say Mr Nawaz Sharif is the most popular
leader some say over one year the
popularity of Mr Khan has deteriorated
this there are others who say he's a
popular leader so the polls are
different but if we wanted to arrest him
and if we wanted to silence him because
of his popularity we wouldn't have
waited for 14 months because Mr Khan
when he became the Prime Minister my
chief minister my leader Mr shabash
Sharif the opposition leader of Pakistan
was arrested within a month there are
rumors that the government wants to
disqualify Imran Khan from future
elections is that on the cards no why
would we do that no political party no
democratic government would want to do
that but Mr Khan did want to do do that
to pmln and other political parties by
arresting all the political leaders of
the political parties and putting them
in jail and silencing them in the first
month of coming into Power people took
to the streets to exercise their
Democratic rights by burning ambulances
not everyone was better ambulance Madam
I think then you were not aware of the
fact I can give you evidence I was on
the ground if you were on the ground
then you must have seen Bridges Metro
Railway stations uh the footpaths the
ambulances the hospital the mosques and
the schools were set on fire have you
seen and you're suggesting have you seen
those
terrorists if if if
the same thing the visuals
if the hospitals or the state
institutions the state buildings
radio Pakistan
the Pakistan television if ambulances
are set
on fire by political workers in your
country will the police react
the place will always try and bring a
situation under control and that's what
we did that's what we did
exactly the police did not react the
police was managing when the core
Commander house was set on fire with the
family inside
don't you think that the armed forces
have the force and the weapons to manage
that there was a responsible responsible
withdrawal there was a responsible
restraint and by the police also in the
entire country where all these
installations were set on fire do you
recognize that there are peaceful people
that believe
the way that Imran Khan was arrested was
unlawful unacceptable a stain on the
country I did not see those peaceful
peoples on the streets in last three
days all I saw but do you recognize I
didn't see that I didn't see that anger
from from General Public you don't think
that I didn't I didn't I didn't I didn't
see there are supporters there are
followers who
refused even if they were followers of
Mr Khan refused this terrorism and to be
part of this inciting violence